cercado el presidente peruano pedro
castillo defendió su gestión y denunció
campaña para destituirlo durante su
discurso a la nación en el congreso por
la conmemoración de la independencia de
perú fecha en la que juramento en el
cargo hace un año
desestabilizan y reclaman la vacancia
no por falta de resultados o por
inexistentes imputaciones que nunca
aprobaran sino por defender sus
intereses privados y por ende por evitar
los cambios que mi gobierno se empeñan
en cumplir el mandatario se ha
enfrentado a dos mociones de vacancia y
cuenta con cinco investigaciones
fiscales en proceso cuatro de ellas por
hechos ocurridos durante su gestión pero
castillo desmiente todo tipo de
acusaciones porque a los medios
empeñados en desestabilizar el gobierno
no les interesa difundir los logros sólo
se emiten mentiras y noticias falsas de
pedro castillo solo se emiten esas cosas
acusado de corrupción sin ninguna prueba
se va a cansar de buscar las pruebas
porque no la van a encontrar
sin embargo las confesiones de su ex
secretario de presidencia y hombre de
confianza
bruno pacheco apuntan directamente al
mandatario y a su entorno pero esto no
es lo único que preocupa el pueblo
peruano y a la oposición
líder de izquierda ha incumplido 51
promesas entre ellas renunciar a el
sueldo presidencial y a la pensión
vitalicia asignar el 10% del pib a la
educación fortalecer 4.000 centros de
salud entre otras y ha tenido 59
ministros en un año una cifra que da
cuenta de la inestabilidad al interior
del ejecutivo debo admitir que hemos
cometido errores con algunas
designaciones así como brindar confianza
a quienes se aprovecharon y burlaron de
ella aunque extendió su mano a la
oposición para trabajar juntos por el
bien del pueblo su mensaje finalizó de
manera accidentada
entre tanto cientos de personas
marcharon en lima la capital a favor y
en contra del presidente algunos
pidiendo el cierre del congreso y otros
su renuncia
[Música]